so tell me netflix was the backlash from
cuties not enough
give me some of the pain and let me die
the realm do you know what the realm is
it's the thousand blades of aegon's
enemies
a story we agree to tell each other over
and over till we forget that it's a lie
what's up ladies and gentlemen welcome
back for another video about david
benioff and db weiss
that's right in this video i want to
discuss the recent news that has been
making headlines on the internet over
the last few days
some of you might not know this but the
writers and showrunners from game of
thrones are now working on a new series
for netflix
and i want to give my thoughts on
whether i think this was a good idea or
not
now before i give my thoughts on the new
show let me give you some of the info
on what this is all about according to
entertainment weekly
they said game of thrones showrunners
david benioff and dan weiss have
announced their next tv series
once again they are adapting an
acclaimed series of novels
only this time in the realm of sci-fi
just for the record
i am a very big fan of scifi it might be
one of my favorite genres so this
definitely has me interested after
reading what it's about
however i am somewhat concerned because
of who will be running the show
david and dan are joining their forces
with the writer and producer alexander
wu
who worked on true blood together they
will tackle
lose the three-body problem trilogy
which depicts humanity's first contact
with an alien civilization
now i know i butchered his last name so
from here on out i will only refer to
him as lou
the saga's debut book was published to a
considerable acclaim in china in 2008
while an english translation by ken liu
became the first asian novel ever
to win a hugo award for best novel in
2014.
the new yorker dub liu chyna's arthur c
clarke
referring to the 2001 a space odyssey
screenwriter
lou's trilogy is the most ambitious
science fiction
series we've read taken readers on a
journey from the 1960s until the end of
time
from life on our pale blue dot to the
distant fringes of the universe
benny often weiss said in a statement we
look forward to spending the next years
of our lives bringing this to life for
audiences around the world
now i do wonder how many years are they
willing to invest
into this new series because after a
while they got sick and tired of working
on game of thrones
they more or less said they wanted to
move on to other things because they
spent so many years making that one show
what will they do if this show becomes
very successful
and netflix once more seasons will they
honor their commitment
or will they run this series into the
ground as well so they can prematurely
evacuate
like they did with george rr martin's a
song of ice and fire adaption
let's see what else is said it is a
privilege to be adapting
one of the great masterpieces of chinese
science fiction
the three-body problem trilogy combines
so many things i love
rich multi-layered characters and true
existential stakes
all told as an elegant and deeply human
allegory
the title refers to a problem in physics
of computing the trajectory of three
bodies interacting with one another
in the novel a nearby solar system where
three stars make life hell for those who
live on an earth-like planet
lou and ken liu will serve as consulting
producers on the project
the author released a statement that
seems to anticipate criticism about
benioff and weiss adapting
an english language adaption of a
chinese novel
i have the greatest respect for and
faith in the creative team
adapting the three-body problem for
television audiences
liu said i set out to tell a story that
transcends time
and the confines of nations cultures and
races
one that compels us to consider the fate
of humankind as a whole
it is a great honor as an author to see
this unique sci-fi concept
travel and gain fandom across the globe
and i am excited for new and existing
fans all over the world to discover the
story on netflix
once again dan and dave's jedi mind
tricks must be at the height of their
powers
it should be very interesting to see how
well they adapt this body of work
i actually can't wait to watch this for
the same reasons we all slow down to
look at a wrecked car on the side of the
road
among the many executive producers on
the project are some familiar names
star wars the last jedi writer director
ryan johnson
wow netflix actually assembled the holy
trinity of stupidity
that's outstanding also game of thrones
veteran bernadette caulfield
actor brad pitt via his entertainment
production company
and actress roseman pike via her
production company
now all jokes aside i will say this
dan and dave are not that bad when they
have source material to adapt
as far as i know the sci-fi books they
are adapting for this netflix series
are completed so they do have that in
their favor
the only thing is how much do they love
this new book series
are they simply making this show because
of all the money they will be getting
now i'm only speculating here but i
honestly do think dan and dave did love
the first three or three and a half
books and a song of ice and fire
i think that's why the first four
seasons were so great but
for whatever reason they did not want to
adapt books four and five the same way
they did with the first three
that makes me think they did not care
about them as much
which is why they ran through that
material as fast as they could
now i don't only want to give my opinion
so let's see what some of the fans have
to say
david benioff i mean david watson says
benioff and weiss are the greatest
writers and producers on the planet
game of thrones receive 59 emmys under
the control of these guys
season 8 of game of thrones walked off
with 12 emmy wins
including for best drama series networks
and streaming services would kill for
those trophies
now let's put things into perspective we
all would agree that marvel's end game
was the biggest movie of 2019
certainly it made the most money at the
box office than any movie in history
it even trumps lord of the rings in the
box office department
what about oscars how many oscars did
endgame receive
wait wait oh that's right end game did
not receive one oscar trophy
it's sounding more like end game was
more of a rollercoaster ride than a
great story
don't you agree whereas game of thrones
is a great story
and has 59 emmy trophies to back it up
game of thrones season 8 long
night episode was much better than
marvel's end game by the way
now i have not seen marvel's endgame so
i can't speak to most of what he said
here
saying benioff and weiss are the
greatest writers has to be a joke
but i will agree with one thing that he
said networks do want to win awards
there's no question about that
but at what cost are they willing to
sacrifice the story to showcase the
actors in less interesting ways to win
awards
i don't know but that's what dan and
dave did for a few seasons at the very
least
robert said here's to hoping they have
lots of source material
silva says i've honestly not heard of
this series of novels but i am intrigued
hopefully the series turns out great
let's hope dumb and dumber don't get
bored halfway through and decide to
dumpster fire russian ending so they can
get away and do something else
they took a huge dump all over game of
thrones and its fan base with that final
season
yikes do you even dare invest any of
your time
into anything dumb and dumber makes
after they completely messed up
something that could have been so
amazing
this duo gets bored so fast and is
always looking for the next best thing
they obviously do not know how fabulous
something is even if it's right in front
of them disney made the ultimate best
decision with ditching them early from
star wars
as you can see i'm still furious with
how they killed game of thrones
no other show should ever have to suffer
i'm done with this writing duo
i will not give them any more of my time
after that big middle finger to loyal
fans of game of thrones
they wanted to get on to their lucrative
contract and didn't even try to pretend
that they gave a damn about the trash
way they ended game
of thrones most of the responses to this
article were negative so i won't bother
reading them all
i think you see where this was heading
what i want to know is how many of you
are interested in watching another show
from these writers
will you be able to invest your time
into something else they adapt
now i'm sure most people who come across
their new series won't know anything
about them but i want to know what all
of you think
considering you know their track record
with game of thrones
i honestly don't see them ever having
another show as successful as thrones
which is why it's so crazy to me that
they were willing to end it the way that
they did
i don't know maybe they knew they had an
offer from star wars long before we ever
found out
so maybe they thought they could do
whatever they wanted and still land a
massive deal
one day i hope someone releases a book
that reveals what was actually happening
behind the scenes of the show
because something obviously happened
that made george r martin
want to distance himself from the show
forever not only did he stop writing for
game of thrones
but he stopped watching game of thrones
he even started to promote other shows
like the last kingdom while game of
thrones was releasing new episodes
i mean how crazy is that his
relationship with david and dan became
very sour by the end
it's really kind of sad too because you
could see that george rr martin was
excited about the show during the early
seasons but by the end of its run
he did not want to even acknowledge its
existence
i know we can speculate about what
happened behind the scenes but i would
love to know what really went down
i think one day we will anyways let me
know down below
will you watch dan and dave's new series
on netflix
i know i'm gonna have to check it out at
least one episode just to see what they
do with it
something tells me netflix won't get the
support they are looking for but hey
what do i know now i do want to make an
announcement before i go
my girlfriend and i are making a video
together on the scott and lacey peterson
case
and it will most likely be over an hour
long because we dive into all the
details of the case
and believe me there is a lot to discuss
i will upload that video within a few
days
if you like it make sure you let us know
because we will make more of them
if there is a demand for it i am
interested in seeing how everyone
responds to that video
so be on the lookout for that as well as
all my other videos
i want to thank everyone for stopping by
and showing your support i hope you all
have a great day
i will see you again very soon bye
[Music]
[Music]
foreign